hey everybody destiny Gary here with
Josh norm our tech editor and we're
gonna be talking about the 20 18 the 20
atti I got a little bit of hands-on time
i pre-ordered one I'm really really
excited to hear what you discovered
about the benchmarking and the stats how
are they doing
yeah the r-tx 2080 in RTX 28 ET i are
the brand new GPUs from nvidia they were
launched at Gamescom of course really
really big deal because we haven't seen
a new GPU since you know like 20 I think
I only think about a year and a half Wow
since 1080i came out basically it's been
a long long good so finally got the
cards reviewer Matt Clark has been
testing it for the last week or so
reviews went up this morning and overall
I mean we're kind of we're really sure
what to expect you know Nvidia talked
about ray tracing pretty much the entire
event when we were in Germany and it's
not going to be out for a while ray
tracing isn't coming right so these
these are the first GPUs that will
actually do real-time ray tracing which
is basically instead of just light
having light being sort of design and
paint it into a game it just sort of
light works like a normal light would
work in the real world so it's
incredibly you know codec it's really
cool it's also incredibly difficult to
do in real time and so they they learn
to show off what that looked like in
Germany so much all we saw so now that
the cards are actually launching and
today is the 19th they'll be physically
available tomorrow on the 20th
unfortunately there's not any games that
are out that are actually playable with
this technology and I'm at the very
moment when can we expect oh well it's a
little bit of a guessing game according
to what I've read that we need Nvidia
needs to basically release you know
Nvidia and the game developers have to
work out you know how this how the
technology gets implemented in games and
so the two biggest ones are maybe three
actually are battlefield 5 which is
going to coming out in November and also
in the shadow of the Tomb Raider which
is out now but has not been patched for
the ray-tracing yet because apparently
they're actually waiting for Microsoft
to update Windows 10 and it's DXR
functionality in there which will
probably happen somewhere around October
or so so if you got one of these cars
are pre-ordered or you're thinking about
it there's a 20 80 to 20 80 TI but I
have a 1080 Ti
how does it stack up
yeah so I think a lot of people you know
myself included were you kind of you
kind of knew because the 2828 eti is a
$1200 G for you it's massive in size has
almost 19 billion transistors you kind
of knew that was gonna be powerful and
you know whatever not really in
competition with anything else but 2080
though it's $800 so it's about 100 150
dollars more than the current 10 atti so
that's I think was a lot of people were
kind of curious about is it faster you
know what's gonna happen you know Nvidia
so there were some leaks that videos
reviewers guide came out and it is they
were showing about 10% improvement or so
so in our testing the r-tx 2080 and the
gtx 1080i are basically about the same
okay so super super close depends on the
game they're both roughly equivalent
able to do 4k 60 frames a second
depending on your settings but the main
difference is that the 1080 TI what it
offers you right now is that's that's
all it's gonna ever offer you it's gonna
be fast but that's that's basically it
the 2080 I mean it's an interesting card
because there's basically this unknown
you know unknown technologies that are
baked into it the rent the ray-tracing
stuff and the deep learning super
sampling which which is something that
may you know it's something coming out
for games but we don't know how many how
many games are gonna use it what its
gonna be like what its gonna do we have
to wait and see so if those are
interesting u20 atti pretty good
investment if not 10 80 TI it's probably
gonna be just fine 20 80 all right
you're right the 2018 let's talk about
the 20 80 TI seeing I made that mistake
right there the 20 80 TI the most
powerful card in the market that's what
their marketing and as they showed all
the cool tech on the twenty eighty at
Gamescom what did you find out in your
testing yeah so the 20 80 TI twelve-hour
dollar GPU of course exists in a
completely different realm than you know
any any other GPU it's for fun one who's
running a 4k monitor and they want to be
you know beyond 60 Hertz you know in our
test it was between 60 and 80 frames a
second and every game we did substantial
substantial increase from 1080i
about you know I mean it's just it's a
super super powerful card looking at
some of your stats some of the games we
talked about on there this has me
incredibly excited Monster Hunter on a
1080 TI running around 33 jump
into the sixties right yeah they've got
that to me I haven't played that game
but that that to me sounds like it's
kind of been like a poorly optimized
possible but yeah it's almost double the
1080i and for a monster owner
it was eighty to eighty two point seven
frames a second and these gee these
tests are at 4k sixty right these are
all 4k exactly yeah it was a you know
almost 80 80 frames a second in
battlefield one ultra settings at 4k
it's just like four I mean I don't know
if you can really understand but 4k will
just kill a graphics card like you know
you might think it's just a it's a huge
jump from 2560 you know so it's 1,200
bucks they're all sold out you can't buy
one anywhere maybe they'll change in the
near future and right now we're getting
some partner cards in from both ZOTAC
and a suits that are 28 et eyes as well
so you can compare them with the bounds
edition but for now it's going to be the
king for the foreseeable future easily
alright I am incredibly excited anything
else we missed that you want to head on
before we go that's really about it
these cards are all shipping now
everyone everyone wanted to wait wait
for benchmarks the benchmarks are out
unfortunately you have to wait a little
bit longer to buy a card because as far
as like before I can tell they're sold
out everywhere so a lot of interest
huge huge you know news in the GPU world
and they're both darn powerful all right
thank you so much Josh for more on all
things Nvidia you're already in the
right place IGN